[Musica]
gravità sono stato chiamato qui proprio
per parlare di questo concetto la
gravità con la gravità io ci gioco sono
soggetto alla gravità esattamente come
lo siamo tutti noi qui dentro e anche
fuori
però io ci gioco ci gioco perché
immaginate quando uscito da un aereo vi
lanciate giù a 250 all'ora e vedete
quella terra che si avvicina e le ditte
cavolo se la percepisco questa gravità
quando però sei anche in montagna e di 6
su pareti molto ripide anche il terreno
instabile magari aiuta a percepire
ancora un altro concetto di gravità
perché lì dice cavolo la sto sentendo
attimo per attimo ma devo stare molto
attento a non farmi prendere da questa
gravità altrimenti sarebbe probabilmente
l'ultima volta e poi quando sono
sott'acqua sott'acqua e un'altra gravità
perché siamo soggetti al fluido
all'acqua in questo caso ok quindi devi
combattere per riuscire andare giù
quindi andare verso quella gravità che
paradossalmente ti rimanda su perché
faccio tutto questo vi chiederete
il motivo è molto semplice perché mi
piace e non confondiamo che fare ciò che
piace sia per forza di cose una cosa
semplice è una grande fortuna ma non è
semplice
questo è bellissimo euro di linea è
sicuramente un mezzo motore che
rappresenta questo concetto di gravità
che cosa meglio di un aereo è perché un
aereo di linea
beh se avessi messo un caccia avesse
messo un aereo che utilizzano i
paracadutisti magari molti di noi qui
dentro o coloro che guardano questo
video non potrebbero capire bene il
concetto di volo questo è lo di lino
nero potente e nero con quattro motori
ovvero che proventi abbiamo preso quasi
tutti quando salite avete presente
l'equipaggio le hostess e gli steward
che vi fanno presenti quelli che sono
procedure d'emergenza nel momento in cui
dovesse succedere qualcosa una di queste
è proprio quella maschera gialla che
cade vi fanno vedere che dovrebbe cadere
da sopra la vostra testa con un
sacchetto sotto di metterla bene
posizionarla davanti alla bocca
appunto in caso d'emergenza vi siete mai
chiesti il motivo e vi siete soprattutto
mai chiesti il motivo di quando siete
tranquillamente seduti su questi comodi
seggiolini e leggete il vostro giornale
come fate a farlo
siete in altissima quota e in altissima
quota che cosa manca manca l'ossigeno ce
n'è pochissimo e quindi voi potete
tranquillamente volare noi possiamo
tutti volare guardando fuori dal
finestrino come se fosse un treno una
macchina a hicks migliaia di metri dal
suolo perché perché di ieri sono
pressurizzati beh quello che ho detto
fino in questo momento qua riguardo
l'aereo non c'entra nulla con quello di
cui vi voglio parlare quest'oggi salvo
la parte finale ho voluto condividere
con voi questa immagine che risale a
qualche settimana fa in italia ed era
nell'ora del tramonto sono io con un
amico in pira caduta libera e sono
avvolto da questi raggi del sole al
tramonto quando so che la pianura la
terra dove vivono tutti e ormai avvolta
da questa da questo buio della sera
beh in questa foto
io avevo il motore più forte più potente
più potendo ancora di 4 motori del 747
della foto di prima ed è il motore più
forte che abbiamo tutti sia uno che si
lanci da un aereo sia voi che state
quasi tutti ed è il sogno il sogno è
quel motore che vi fa andare oltre le
montagne che vi fa fare quel lancio che
magari vi fa fare anche un tuffo perché
lo volete lo volete fortemente qualcosa
che sentite dentro però
ognuno lo realizza proprio modo nel mio
caso lo realizzò scalando volando
nuotando piuttosto che correndo
pedalando e molto altro attraverso i
luoghi più remoti del pianeta i moduli
difficili ma chi me lo fa fare meglio
fare questo sogno
cercate sempre di realizzare i vostri
sogni
sognare non costa nulla lo possiamo fare
in qualunque momento ad occhi chiusi ad
occhi aperti
qui o dall'altra parte del mondo su un
aereo che in un attimo ci porta chissà
dove
sognare è bello sognare non costa nulla
facciamolo facciamolo perché il sogno
non ha età
sfatiamo quell'idea che è giusto che
sognino i giovani perché chi non è più
giovani ormai la sua vita l'ha fatta no
sogniamo sogniamo e andiamo fieri dei
nostri sogni e continuiamo a volere
cercare di realizzarle ovvio che cercare
di realizzarli è la parte più difficile
più dura ma senza la difficoltà la vita
sarebbe una noia
lo squalo probabilmente il simbolo della
paura questo muscolo fisico l'ho messo
per un legame molto forte a un'avventura
che nel 2015 mi ha portato a nuotare
vicino a questi bellissimi e splendidi
animali
amo gli animali tutti gli squali sono
probabilmente uno degli animali che amo
di più ma amare un animale non vuol dire
essere stupido e non averne paura
lo squalo e fisico ma lo squalo spesso e
volentieri rappresenta la paura che può
essere dentro ognuno di noi
la paura però non deve essere vista come
una cosa negativa
la paura è l'emozione più bella che
possiamo provare e quell'emozione che ti
mantiene vivo vigile attento in
equilibrio
e vero io nel caso personale spesso
sento che gioco tra una parte e l'altra
ma è la mia vita mi piace viverla così
sono sereno però sono consapevole che
che la paura è quella che mi tiene lì la
paura può prendere due strade
l'eccesso di paura che un qualcosa che
troppo spesso la gente tende a
paragonare la paura come panico no il
panico e la mancanza di controllo della
paura
è questa la differenza e spesso si ha
paura di che cosa di ciò che non si
conosce
di ciò che non sia approvato e come si
può superare quella paura e quindi
prenderne il controllo
se non andandoci dentro facendo un passo
magari un tuffo dentro la paura di
ognuno di noi affrontiamo nelle paure
non abbiamo non abbiate e non abbiamo
mai paura di avere paura se uno piange
se un uomo piazze magari un debole se un
uomo dice no io non me la sento di fare
questa cosa qui non me l'ha
non è dentro di me a sei uno sfigato no
fregato e vi dico che dice la gente fate
quello che sentite dentro una volta però
che anche nelle avventure però cos'è la
ventura io faccio avventure estreme
malaventura cos'è la ventura e la vita e
io ho fatto nella mia vita una ventura
ma questo è un altro discorso
si sa benissimo che quando arriva la
paura che è presente spesso e volentieri
ma quando si decide di fare un qualcosa
di molto importante
magari l'apparenza anche pericoloso
questa paura la celtic è lì che dice
prendo e controllo di te e arriva quel
momento che uno dice devo fare quel
passo perché altrimenti puoi avere il
sogno poi verrà questa paura che ti fa
vibrare il cuore ti fa dire io questo
sogno che voglio realizzare ma se manca
[Musica]
però birdies e foolish baby gate brown
[Applauso]
se manca il coraggio non vai da nessuna
parte
resti fermo quel momento che avete
appena visto e l'ho voluto condividere
con tutti voi perché uno degli attimi
che mi ricordo che ho dentro di me che
forse mi hanno messo anche più angoscia
aveva una paura in quel momento
lei ma che non avrebbe avuta nel momento
in cui ho detto o che è arrivato
l'attimo dopo un anno e mezzo di
preparazione di allenamento di iniziare
la grande avventura in africa mi trovavo
a zanzibar è un'isola della tanzania ma
ero a 50 km dalla costa africana io lo
dovevo raggiungere ero 50 chilometri di
oceano indiano da nuotare e ho notato in
23 ore non stop senza mai uscire
dall'acqua con tutte le mie paure con
tutte le paure cosa sono cos'erano gli
squali ovvio è chiaro la corrente le
onde altri animali le nazioni fisiche
mie perché siamo sono e siamo soggetti
un'altra gravità in acqua e li medici mi
chiedevano non sappiamo mi dicevano non
sappiamo come potrebbe reagire il tuo
fisico dopo così tante ore immerso in un
liquido a differente gravità perché gli
organi interni possono avere dei
problemi
tu potresti svenire in acqua nelle onde
di notte perché 23 ora vuol dire fare
tutta la notte il mare nero e vero mi
sono posto tutte queste domande di
solito quando faccio un'avventura
calcolo il 98 per cento delle
probabilità possibilità fatti che mi
possono succedere il 2 per cento
rimanente è l'incognita è l'incognita
cos'è e avventura
se non ci fosse quel 2 per cento ma
secondo voi io andrei direi anche di no
assolutamente sarebbe estremamente
noioso e la noia tende a uccidere
l'essere umano dentro quando si fa quel
tuffo quando sei dentro quando entri la
paura ti accorgi che la pesantezza che
avevi dettata da questo senso di forse
anche angoscia si è trasformata in
leggerezza proventi tre ore sono tante
voi fate questo tuffo nel buio della
vostra paura perché volete affrontarla
la prendete di te io ce la farò
ok però 23 ore possono essere giorni
perché altre situazioni la paura torna
perché bussei dice ehi guarda che io
adesso tono prendere il controllo di te
ed è in quel momento lì che viene fuori
il carattere
e voi avete presente quando uno nuota
immaginate di nuotare in questo mare
nero genero come il petrolio quindi lo
stile libero è una bracciata poi
un'altra e di solito la terza cosa fai
ti ri sulla testa perché devi respirare
giustamente po tutti abbiamo provato a
nuotare anche in piscina o in mare e
questo è quindi io mi son detto come
faccio a staccare quella paura che
comunque torna perché inevitabilmente
deve tornare visto che quello che posso
guardare solo il nero è vero che per
risolvere un problema per risolvere una
paura bisogna spezzettarla in parti
sempre più piccole cercare di vivere il
momento perché il momento l'attimo e la
vita la vita non è nel passato e non è
il futuro a vita e l'attimo dopo spesso
sono proiettati in un futuro in un
passato magari anche vicini e questo non
si fa vivere e ci fa creare
dell'angoscia inesistenti però cavolo
con la paura continuava e allora mi son
detto come faccia l'ho pensata lo
ripensata sempre col sorriso sempre con
lo spirito
cos'è ioltre un mare nero
un mare di stelle luminose questa foto è
stata scattata all'arrivo sulla costa
africana precisamente a bagamoyo in
tanzania
siamo a nord di dar es salam ed è un
ricordo favoloso ma soprattutto ricordo
queste stelle luminose che mi hanno
guidato in questi cinquanta chilometri
di fatica ma di grande soddisfazione
quindi quello che dico e cercate quando
siete nella difficoltà più nera quelle
stelle luminose che sono dentro ognuno
di noi perché ci sono e ci sono per un
semplice motivo siamo vivi e ovvio che
io ho dato un po il mio punto di vista
adesso sta a voi cercare quelli che
possono essere davanti a alla vostra
vita o dentro di voi le montagne
impervie e deserti aridi piuttosto che
oceani burrascosi quello che volete voi
quello che vi posso solo dire
affrontateli affrontateli e adesso per
ritornare alla promessa iniziale perché
mi piace mantenere queste promesse e è
anche soprattutto consegnare un
messaggio questo mio messaggio
importante lo voglio chiudere mostrando
un po voi quello che quello che si prova
anche se con un breve video a quella
quota di crociera di un aereo di linea
dove tutti noi voliamo e guardiamo fuori
da questo finestrino ecco cosa si può
provare essere fuori da quel finestrino
e trovarsi a oltre 8.000 metri dove
l'ossigeno e minimo dove la gravità si
sente tanto anche la pressione e quelle
vette oltre gli ottomila metri oltre ad
essere la dimora degli dei
per me è anche la dimora di grande
emozione
grazie
[Applauso]